this episode was brought to you by
morningbrew
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
blockchain and cryptocurrencies burst
onto the scene just after the 2008
financial crash
it was a symbolic warning that something
might be wrong with our current economic
system
12 years later the majority of
structural problems
since 2008 haven't been fixed in fact
many of those problems are much worse
so what happened to the crypto and
blockchain revolution and why haven't we
been hearing about it
well the fact is a lot has happened in
that time but the news cycle is just
focusing on other things
in this episode we'll take a look at
some of the major milestones that are
taking place in the field of business
finance and even government key aspects
of the financial system
might be starting to change right in
front of our eyes
it's worth noting that although we've
covered a few crypto scams on this
channel
as entertaining as they were there are
also a mountain of legitimate uses for
this technology as you'll soon see
you are watching cold fusion tv
so starting off if you haven't watched
my 2017 blockchain series yet it's a
good watch to get some background
one viewer even used it as the basis for
his final year thesis
i'll leave a link for that series below
so what is blockchain to summarize
blockchain is an unalterable digital
list
this digital list has a record of who
owns what
the key point is that the list can't be
tampered with
this is because an up-to-date copy of
this list of who owns what
is stored on the computer of every
member in the system
if someone tries to mess with an entry
on this list it's not going to match the
rest of the entries in the system
this renders the tampering invalid
that's a very oversimplified overview
but that's the core idea
and this very idea is proving to be a
powerful tool
from blockchain came cryptocurrencies
and a lot of other technologies
the biggest story in blockchain right
now has to be defy
or decentralized finance imagine being
able to take out a loan without having
to speak to anyone or even open up a
bank account
or gain a six percent interest on your
savings deposit without a bank
signing anything or even interacting
with anyone either
this and much more already exist today
and it's gotten simple enough
that anyone with a phone can pick it up
and take part
all you need is a defy app and some
money that you want to spend
it works something like this you deposit
your dollars or government currency
and the app automatically converts it to
a crypto of your choosing
you can use these holdings as collateral
to loan against
you can also get interest on your
deposit depending on how volatile the
crypto is
the less volatile the higher the
interest rate
defy applications are built on top of a
cryptocurrency called ethereum
ethereum unlike bitcoin manages to do
this through something called a smart
contract a smart contract
is essentially a digital contract made
of code its job is to replace what a
human intermediary would do
the code in the smart contract writes up
the terms of the agreement
and enforces the rules all within the
same program
no humans required some smart contracts
are written so they're tied to
real-world assets
an example of this is something called a
stable coin
a stable coin derives its value from an
underlying currency
like the us dollar for example other
smart contracts can be tied to gold or a
stock
the possibilities are endless and in my
view
throughout history making complicated
but valuable things easy for the average
person to use
has been the hallmarks of every game
changer
so d fire could be a game changer or
just another bubble
you'd have to be very careful of putting
any of your money in these things
since it's at such an early stage and
there's probably many bad actors out
there
but regardless the concept is very
interesting and i'll be keeping my eye
on it
continuing on in the world of finance
with blockchain the world's largest
refiner of newly minted gold
the perth mint which holds over 3.2
billion us dollars of gold within its
vaults
is launching the first government gold
guaranteed digital asset
titled perth mint gold token
this means that through the use of
cryptocurrency you can own gold within a
vault
this is in stark contrast to other
tokens on the market which are often
not including stable coins backed by
nothing of value in the real world
but rather by a combination of its
rarity and the effort it takes to mine
seeing that you're interested in a video
like this and presumably the latest in
finance tech or business
you might like to try out this episode's
sponsor morning brew
morning brew gives you a free daily
newsletter each weekday
these newsletters go straight to your
inbox and makes news less dry
and boring during a quick browse this
week i recently learnt about flippy the
robot
a robot that can make burgers using
computer vision
it's the first of its kind and is
projected to increase profit margins by
300 percent
i think the morning brew format is good
because you can be up to date with key
news stories without having to manually
trundle across multiple sources
so really there's no reason not to
subscribe to morning brew if you're
interested in business
technology or finance it's completely
free and takes less than 15 seconds to
subscribe
click the link in the description below
to subscribe to morning brew today
okay continuing on with the episode in
italy
85 of banks now use a blockchain system
called corda
previously banks in italy sent physical
tapes between each other
in order to reconsolidate transfers
between the banks
this meant that the process could take
between one to two months to complete
now with the help of quarter
authenticated and reliable
reconsolidation is completed within 24
hours
it seems that every bank and financial
institution is finding uses for
blockchain and cryptocurrencies
a couple of swiss banks have recently
been given approval to offer
cryptocurrency trading
mastercard visa and paypal are all
pivoting their services to incorporate
crypto and blockchain
we're very excited about blockchain
technology uh we have been working with
it for quite a while
uh we have partners we work with it on
we have a product we're piloting that
uses distributed ledger technology
uh blockchain we think uh is is a
potentially very valuable technology
jp morgan successfully tested their
multiple currency prototype with
singaporean financial authorities
this was five years in the making this
payment network
aims to make cheaper and faster
international money transfers
and is already being rolled out
okay so next let's take a look at
blockchain and business
in logistics the use of middlemen
tracking and storage can create problems
that drastically impact a company's
efficiency
chronicled a california-based company is
integrating blockchain
and internet of things systems in order
to create a more efficient logistics
system they recently partnered with a
large pharmaceutical company to help
transport their products
with the authentication of each
product's origin this process
not only makes transportation more
efficient but it also makes it more
difficult for bad actors to try and
intercept the supply chain to switch out
items with counterfeit products
blockchain is also being implemented by
some tech giants
earlier this year microsoft introduced
lithian
a blockchain that integrates into
microsoft's cloud computing service
azure this allows developers to
integrate blockchain solutions into
their apps
last year samsung integrated a
blockchain wallet into their smartphones
with the unveiling of the s10 this gives
way to the use of decentralized apps or
d-apps
d-apps give developers the opportunity
to integrate blockchain into mobile
applications
while it's still in its infancy d-apps
ranging from health
to social media platforms and charity
are already being developed
far from the offices of big banks or
mechanical manufacturing flaws
the famed cryptocurrency bitcoin is
helping advance the semiconductor
industry
interestingly the pursuit of faster and
more efficient problem solving has
increased demand for semiconductors due
to bitcoin mining
bitcoin mining is the act that gives the
coin its value by making it a rarity
the mining process is credited by some
analysts as one of the leading causes of
recent advancements in the semiconductor
industry
in south africa tamela ramaphosa son of
the president
is trying to tackle the issue of illegal
poaching which has ravaged the country's
wildlife in the name of greed
his product stud x works in partnership
with ibm
to use the internet of things and
blockchain to verify
the ownership of animals the idea is to
track an individual animal's movements
heart rate and more and put all of this
data on a blockchain
this creates another layer of difficulty
for poachers to illegally sell
and illegally attain animals
so statics is the first cryptocurrency
for
rare and endangered wildlife it's an
investment platform
for profit so it's the digital
equivalent of a
stock exchange for for wildlife and
livestock certain percentages now within
the transaction cost as well
between the farmers and ourselves will
be
dedicated towards conservation so the
whole idea is that we protect animals
from hunters predators approaches and
disease
and that's what the whole idea of owning
a token is is that
you're supporting anti-poaching
technology
and you support supporting anti-poaching
initiatives towards supporting this
animal in its natural environment
so in this last section we're going to
see how blockchain is starting to make
its way into government
recently the united states postal
service just issued a blockchain patent
this was to secure mail-in voting
disclaimer
i'm not an american and i have no stake
in this issue i'm just giving you the
information on this one
china japan canada britain south korea
and many other countries are talking
about making big moves into
cryptocurrencies
meanwhile the united states and other
major global economies
are struggling to change and adapt to
the rapid pace of blockchain development
emerging economies across asia and
africa are embracing advancements in
fintech and blockchain
these efforts provide attractive
economic opportunities that don't
discriminate based on nationality
wealth or credit legacy financial
institutions
may struggle to compete unproductive
participants could lose market share
some analysts are predicting a return to
healthy competition in the financial
sector
we'll have to wait and see on that one
the central banks of governments around
the world are focusing their efforts on
blockchain
continuing a trend of developing a
digital version of existing currencies
britain is reviewing the development of
a digital pound
thailand is in the development for its
own digital currency
and japan is planning trials for their
digital yen
but china is leading the way the central
bank of china
is beginning to test the digital yuan
this was done through a selected group
of whitelisted employees
this trial if successful could usher in
a new wave of adoption
with four of the largest banks in the
world ranked by assets all being in
china
and lastly the chinese government is
planning to implement the digital
currency at the 2022
beijing winter olympics
[Music]
meanwhile in south korea the government
plans to invest nearly 50 billion
dollars into what they call
the fourth industrial revolution the
digital civilization
this includes the implementation of
blockchain solutions by 2025.
the implementation of cryptocurrencies
is not constrained to just governments
in fact there appear to be many examples
where digital coins are being used due
to a lack of government leadership
recently hong kong passed legislation
which would allow governments to freeze
and confiscate people's assets
this has raised fears that it may be
used for a tool to suppress speech
particularly those who aren't fond of
the chinese government
soon after the laws are enacted certain
stable coins
coins which are tied to existing
real-world currencies saw an uptick in
value
trading volume rose between hong kong
dollars and the u.s stablecoin
which is pegged to the us dollar this
suggests that whoever is trading
be it a handful of wealthy individuals
or a mass number of the average citizens
whoever it is these people in hong kong
were cautious of the new law
and they were taking things into their
own hands by protecting their assets
by converting to a more flexible and
easier to transfer
store of wealth brazil
recently hard hit by the kovan 19
pandemic saw its economy struggle
during these times the national currency
dipped to a record low
this caused the nation to also see a
similar uptick in the trading volumes of
stable coins
this now seems to be a new global trend
among poorly performing economies
when currencies are failing and trust in
government is diminishing
it seems that individuals within these
troubled economies are turning to
cryptocurrencies to preserve their
wealth
even in the united states a study as
reported by forbes revealed that 15
of american adults now own a form of
cryptocurrency
and about half of those were first-time
buyers this year
why would the banks disrupt themselves
by introducing
a digital currency that would make it
easier
for consumers and businesses to
disintermediate the banks
well the banks may not be the innovators
it may be that they are the reactors
that they will react
when others innovate right now digital
currency sounds very edgy and uh kind of
alternative lifestyle
but it's it's becoming the mainstream
and so the banks
uh the largest banks in particular are
very aware of this they're investing in
the technology
and they will provide this service um as
soon as it's profitable enough
after considering the cost to them
of losing some of their current business
that they're going to disrupt
[Music]
so although it's not being discussed in
the media the implementation of
cryptocurrencies to create more secure
assets and the blockchain to automate
more of our economy
seems more relevant now than ever
central banks are now seriously looking
into this technology
while many businesses are finding
innovative uses for blockchain
the boom and bust of the crypto bubble
in 2018 may have quelled some of these
predictions
but taking a deeper look it actually
doesn't seem like cryptocurrencies are
going away
blockchain solutions keep springing up
from fighting poachers
to improving banking to helping citizens
with unstable governments
it really looks like blockchain will be
an important part of our future
so what do you guys think how do you
think the future of blockchain and
crypto will look like
do you think cryptos will continue to
free people from economic boundaries
like in hong kong and brazil
or do you think it would eventually lead
to more central bank control
let me know in the comment section below
so for the five of you that are still
watching i want to thank you for
watching the whole way through this
video
if you do want to learn more about
blockchain i'll leave a link to my
blockchain and crypto series below
if you want to see anything else on
science technology business or history
feel free to subscribe to cold fusion
i'm sure you'll find a lot of
interesting stuff on here
anyway my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion
and i'll catch you again soon for the
next video cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
it's me thinking
you